bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du parlement hebdo en compagnie
michael chamas bonjour michael voici
ensemble pour 45 minutes d'actualité
politique et parlementaire est tout
d'abord cette semaine mardi le vote
solennel du texte sur le mariage pour
tous et mystique le pl a craqué à
l'assemblée 329 voix pour 229 contre le
texte passera au sénat à partir du 2
avril prochain
les sénateurs qui continue les auditions
en ce moment en commission la france
pourra-t-elle tenir son objectif de 3%
de déficit public en 2013
la réponse est non après les doutes de
la cour des comptes le premier ministre
lui-même aimé des réserves sur le
respect nos engagements européens
les députés ump vont déposer une motion
de censure sur la politique économique
du gouvernement
enfin pas moins de trois ministres sur
la sphère de la viande de cheval
trouvaient dans des aliments préparés
deux conférences de presse commune dans
la semaine et des coupables
la société française spanghero se voit
suspendre son agrément sanitaire et les
autorités françaises promettent plus de
contrôle est avec nous pour développer
toute cette actualité david assouline
bonjourbonjour sénateur ps de paris mais
aussi le porte parole du parti
socialiste et vous que l'on voit tous
les lundis rue de solférino tenir ce
point presse il faut faire attention à
la moindre syllabe tous les lundi matins
est ce à dire que comme tous les porte
parole de tous les partis vous avez
appris la langue de bois non c'est pas
la langue de bois c'est je le fais avec
vraiment beaucoup de conviction je pense
que ce gouvernement c'est tout ce qu'il
faut faire pour redresser notre pays et
il le fait par exemple type de la langue
de bois non parce que je le pense
sincèrement si vous voulez on va
développer pourquoi tous les cas surtout
et c'est important pour nous il le fait
en maintenant le cap de la justice dans
ses décisions
et ça c'est la grande différence avec la
droite alors dans cette émission vous le
savez on va écouter c'est une tradition
quelques collègues on va écouter donc
quelques sénateurs pour voir comment ils
vous perçoivent vous propose de les
écouter on réagit juste après oui il
fait polémique
que parce qu'elle intervient à tous
propos sur tous les sujets et lorsqu'ils
s'expriment c'est toujours je dirais
avec fougue et prend son temps
parce qu'il veut convaincre donc ces
interventions sont un peu longues
ce qui agace quelquefois c'est un homme
passionné et qui est excessif
à mon point de vue est excessif dans ses
convictions et dans son engagement et
donc qui peut être à fur et à mesure
apprend la modération mais à petites
doses
il y as chez lui une réelle authenticité
une ferveur militante un engagement
partisan font ça me rappelle ma jeunesse
plutôt de l'autre bord mais s'il peut
garder s'évertuer à prendre un peu le
fond du sujet ça risque d'être un
excellent center vous avez écouté
gérard longuet une certaine ressemblance
avec lui quand il était jeune ça vous
fait plaisir
d'abord je suis plus tout jeune et s'il
veut dire que il a perdu lui avec l'âge
les convictions et la passion peut-être
oui moi je les ai gardés je suis plus
jeune
vous savez rend coup pour coup aussi
visiblement à jeu je me bats pour pour
mes idées je sais effectivement mais
mais vraiment je respecte beaucoup le
débat politique et notamment ceux qui
ont les convictions en face et j'aime le
débat sur le fond et donc des fois les
petites phrases qui nous sont imposées
par par le système médiatique lui même
le côté peu peut pousser à des
caricatures mais moi franchement j'aime
le débat parlementaire j'aime le débat
de fond et j'aime opposé des convictions
à d'autres vraie conviction aller sans
langue de bois et de façon courte
contrairement à ce que disent vos
collègues on va dérouler ensemble
l'actualité de la semaine on commence
avec lundi trois ministres pour une
fraude alimentaire
l'afer est parti d'une alerte en grande
bretagne de la viande de cheval
retrouver dans des lasagnes soi-disant
au boeuf même trouvailles dans des plats
cuisinés en france alors en ce lundi
pas moins de trois ministres convoque la
bresse la presse à bercy pour parler
enquête et traçabilité
c'est un sujet d'elisa bartholomé
désamorcer la bombe
ce lundi à bercy benoît hamon stéphane
le foll et guillaume garot se sont
montrés rassurants avec les
professionnels de la viande et les
associations de consommateurs mobilisés
sur la sphère le gouvernement a pris des
premières mesures d'urgence
nous allons mettre la filière viande et
poisson sous surveillance pour ce qui
relève de l'approvisionnement de la
transformation et de la
commercialisation
toute l'année 2013 de façon ce qu'au
delà devrait dire d'une intensification
conjoncturelle des contrôles on dispose
de la capacité à mesurer l'étendue du
préjudice car déjà la polémique enfle
comment de la viande de cheval a pu être
retrouvée dans des plats aux boeufs
depuis 2002 la réglementation européenne
impose la mention de la provenance de la
viande mais cette obligation concerne
seulement la viande brut pas à les plats
cuisinés les associations de la filière
refuse l'amalgamé et appellent à son
renforcement
ce qu'il faut absolument c'est d'abord
parlé au consommateur lui dire que la
viande française est une viande de
qualité qu'elle est tracé et que la
filière ne doit pas supporter les
préjudices qui sont causés par par des
voyous veuillez pas d'autre mot des
voyous qui ont eu ce juste eu la volonté
de tricher pour des raisons mercantiles
des préjudices pris très au sérieux par
les autorités
une réunion intergouvernementale avec
d'autres pays européens se tiendra en
fin de semaine
à terme l'ensemble des contrôles et des
normes d'étiquetage pourraient être
renforcées
et puis la suite bien sûr c'était jeudi
le ministre benoît hamon qui donne les
résultats de l'enquêté qui se montre
très dur notamment contre la société
française pong héros qui dit il savaient
qu'il s'agissait de cheval david
assouline cinq pays de traders pour un
seul plat cuisiné vous avez découvert
vous aussi la complexité des circuits
alimentaires
oui
je savais que c'était trop compliqué
mais en avait que ce cas d'école
finalement et en lisant tout ce qui a
comme intermédiaire et comme complexité
je pense que ça ne n'êtes pas la
transparence et à dire que des filous
qui veulent jouer sur ces confusions
possibles peuvent passer entre les
mailles
en tous les cas là c'est vraiment la
société qui n'a rien à voir d'ailleurs
avec l'espagne 0 que nous connaissons la
seule inconnue j'allais mis en cause
également sur sauf que c'est sauf que
les sept ans dans cette cuisine ça
rentre avec avec l'étiquetage viande de
cheval en tous les cas le sait ce qui
nous est indiqué pal enquête et ça sort
en viande de boeuf donc là il y a
quelque chose déjà d'identifier qu'il
faut sanctionnée avec la plus grande
sévérité et qu'on puisse spéculer sur
sur la nourriture est absolument
scandaleux c'est à dire qu'il y à un
cynisme ceux qui veulent faire de
l'argent n'importe comment et à
n'importe quel prix quand on pense j'ai
entendu le chiffre de 2 exorbitant du
bénéfice fait juste par ce changement
d'étiquetage c'est c'est incroyable
c'est à dire que même la punition prévu
par la loi est inférieure à l'argent
qu'ils se sont fait d'accord mais enfin
le préjudice financier et donc que qu'on
doit récupérer de toute façon c'est une
crise salutaire quelque part parce que
tout le monde sait réveiller l'europe a
alerté on va faire une nouvelle réunion
à bruxelles également régler ce problème
d'étiquetage quelque part finalement
c'est un mal pour un bien
j'espère que le préjudice est le mal
n'est pas trop important parce que s'il
fallait qu'à chaque fois il ya les
catastrophes pour se réveiller mais en
tous les cas
en tous les cas oui c'est bien que
maintenant on voit et pour les autorités
françaises on l'a vu de façon très
déterminée notamment ce que benoît hamon
a déclaré hier est très rassurant y
compris pour tous les contrôles qui vont
être faits sur l'ensemble de la filière
poisson et viande à partir d'aujourd'hui
fait que les consommateurs peuvent être
sécurisées il faut pas non plus
alimenter le panier qui n'a pas lieu
d'être là parce que en france il y a des
moyens de contrôle et ils sont mises en
oeuvre mais que la commission européenne
que l'europe s'y met c'est absolument
fondamental on peut pas faire mieux en
parler
cette fois c'est en tout cas au niveau
européen très bien je pense que le lia
en quelques jours on a vu une machine se
met en branle et réagir mais parce que
l'enjeu est très important nous à les
consommer sur cette filière
c'est une catastrophe pour tout le monde
et donc heureusement que quand les
enjeux aso à ce niveau tout le monde se
mobilise en tout la cac en tous les cas
la france et est vraiment au point dans
ce domaine allez on va passer au mardi
mariage pour tous adopté 11 jours de
débats intensifs et deux nuits blanches
et on ce mardi le projet de loi sur le
mariage pour tous est votée en première
lecture à l'assemblée presque tous les
députés sont présents 329 voix pour 229
contre et une ovation du côté gauche de
l'hémicycle pour christiane taubira la
ministre c'est thibault le floch qui
nous raconte cette séance un peu
spéciale pour 329 contre 229
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
avec 100 voix d'écart l'assemblée
nationale a adopté en première lecture
le projet de loi sur le mariage pour
tous sur les bancs de la gauche
c'est l'exultation
au coeur il scande le mot égalité
christiane taubira est également au
centre de toutes les attentions ses
collègues viennent embrasser la
féliciter elle qui était au coeur de ce
combat législatif savoure cette victoire
avec lyrisme comme ici quelques minutes
après le vote ce projet de loi nous a
conduits à penser autrui à consentir à
l'altérité pensée autrui disait emmanuel
levinas relève de l'irréductible
inquiétude pour l'autre c'est ce que
nous avons fait tout le long de ce débat
si la gauche a applaudi debout il n'en
va pas de même pour l'opposition qui
n'attend pas la fin du discours de
christiane taubira pour quitter
l'hémicycle
mais juste avant l'heure de
l'explication de vote le principal
opposant au texte hervé mariton n'a pas
oublié de souligner que le combat
n'était pas fini nous nous regardons
vers l'avenir l'avenir s'écrit mieux
avec notre engagement pour la famille
pour les enfants et nous continuerons
notre combat n'abîmez pas l'avenir de la
france
la france mérite impute aux autres
projets d'ailleurs les changes se
poursuit même hors de l'hémicycle avec
dominique bertinotti la ministre de la
famille et franck riester
l'un des trois députés ump qui a voté en
faveur du texte
merci motivante les familles je pense
que c'est un concept qui affaiblit la
famille c'est manifestement un débat
entre nous
l'une en ce texte est davantage un
comptage de famille ça tu peux le mettre
avec ou sans s
exactement c'est faux ça que ça laisse
la porte ouverte tu veux réconcilier et
les échanges vont continuer mais cette
fois au sénat reprise des débats le 2
avril
alors en tant que sénateur david
assouline j'ai suivi ces débats
l'assemblée y compris la nuit oui
beaucoup sur twitter que c'est
exceptionnel ça c'était tout à fait
nouveau parce que le soir comme ça avant
d'aller au lit et je vais je ne sortais
pas parce que ça ça twitte et ça serait
tombé à l'intérieur de l'assemblée
il n'y a pas d'abus dans tous les cas
c'était à ses côtés si l'on peut pas
interdire ce qui ce qui sait ce qui
s'impose après comme toutes les
nouvelles technologies
il faut savoir les maîtriser il faut
savoir les utiliser il faut savoir
rester dans le cadre de la loi
je n'ai pensé quoi de ces débats avec
une petite semaine de recul et bien une
chose contradictoires
d'abord le ska symboliser le brio de la
ministre c'est à dire un débat de fond
aux débats de société un débat oui à des
convictions un débat où on élève le
niveau est elle là c'est bien ça bien
sûr mon fan de christiane taubira pas
nouveau moi j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé
cette femme parce que dans son
engagement politique est tout ouïe arts
et à la poésie
il ya la culture et à la partie sociale
quelque chose n'a pas toujours été qu'un
parti socialiste d'aimer christiane
taubira savait qu'elle avait été
candidat parce qu'il ya longtemps
peut-être en tous les cas je respecte
complètement cette son engagement et la
façon dont elle le mène qui et qui
honore la politique et qu'il a fait mais
alors pourquoi contradictoire parce que
ces cinq mille amendements un moment
donné on voyait bien que ça tourner à la
dérision pouvait pas constamment être
dans la répétition absolue je comprend
quelques centaines d'amendements déjà
c'est beaucoup quand il n'y a que
quelques articles de loi mais des
milliers ça dénature et les choses et la
droite c'est vivre à s'appuyer eu des
dérapages
donc je pense quand même que ce qu'on
retient c'est une fille née une réforme
de société très importante historique et
le fait qu'on a donné un nouveau droit
sans en enlever à personne d'autre et ça
c'est la gauche c'est ce qu'elle a
toujours fait et que la droite soit
encore rester au bord du chemin
regardons ce train passer quelle
rattrapera plus tard parce que je le dis
aussi pourquoi c'est historique parce
que on sent bien que même quand il y
aura une alternance j'espère le plus
tard possible
la droite n'y reviendra pas comme en
espagne elle n'est pas revenue ont quand
même rapide avant de passer justement au
sénat la pma ne faisait pas partie du
texte et le groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée qui a tenu à introduire cet
amendement pm1 est-ce que vous pensez
que c'était une erreur tactique donc
puisqu'il n'a pas été auditionné
s'engouffrer dans la brèche pma
allègrement ne met enfin à partir du
moment où dans le texte qui était
présenté et y compris après passage en
commission à l'assemblée il n'y avait
pas ce sujet que les choses avaient été
clairement dit pour que justement il n'y
ait pas de confusion c'est à dire que ça
viendra dans un texte famille mais que
là on était sur le mariage pour tous le
fait que la droite ait fait semblant de
pas avoir entendu
et quand on regarde les mots les plus
employés par elle sur ses senteurs de
d'intervention quasiment que la droite
parce qu'il parlait tout seul c'était
pas mal j'ai pas peur la gpa pour
consigne de ne pas parler
donc c'est fort que la baisse attendue
les écoutez si à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un amendement de la droite
pour justement retardé on s'était mis
aussi on serait tombés dans le panneau
les débats auraient duré de senteurs de
100 heures pardon et donc c'est vraiment
je veux dire le le débat pma gp a été
agitée pour empêcher le mariage pour
tous et pour créer cette confusion
on va voir ce débat tranquille qui
effectivement et je le dis moi je le
pense la gpa hors de question pour nous
est la pma en tant que tel et je
comprends tout à fait les interrogations
de
de ceux qui les posent je suis peau mais
j'entends que c'est un débat qui n'est
pas de la même nature de que celui sur
ce nouveau droit parce que ce nouveau
droit
et bien il y laissait pas un débat
éthique c'est un débat vraiment de
valeur de notre société
l'égalité c'est la république c'est la
marque de fabrique de la france dans
tous les sénateurs vous allez vous
saisir du texte à partir du 2 avril
prochain
il ne sera pas votée conforme
c'est-à-dire que vous les sénateurs vous
serez sûrement amené à amender un petit
peu ce texte vous savez que au sénat la
majorité ne tient qu'à six sièges alors
est ce qu'il y ait un risque pour ce
texte
l'enquète de joachim robe laisser aux
sénateurs le temps de poursuivre leurs
auditions sur le mariage pour tous le
texte sera donc examiné à partir du 2
avril et non dès la mi mars gouvernement
a pris les dispositions pour que le
débat dure le temps qui paraîtra
nécessaires aux sénateurs et donc si ça
doit être de semaine ce sera ce sera
aussi deux semaines le but permettre aux
sénateurs de modifier le texte adopté
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale dans
le texte il dit à zatta nombre
d'imperfections
il faut faire des coordination voilà
donc que le sénat apportera comme il le
fait toujours d'ailleurs apportera son
côté technique
l'opposition compte utiliser ce délai
pour poursuivre son combat contre le
mariage pour tous nous entendons bien
profiter de cette période de la vie
parlementaire ont exprimé à la fois nos
convictions pour faire part également de
nos propositions dans la bombe un
certain nombre de la science que le
texte soit modifié par rapport celui qui
a été voté par l'assemblée nationale
mais pour les socialistes pas question
d'accepter des amendements sur le fond
sur les deux principaux articles et deux
premiers articles
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
modification substantielle puisque nous
sommes pauvres
le mariage pour tous et l'adoption reste
une question quelle majorité pour voter
ce texte les socialistes qui devrait
connaître quelques abstentions compte
sur le soutien de certains sénateurs ump
alors david assouline quand on compte
les sénateurs qui sont apparentés
socialistes les radicaux les élus
d'outre-mer qui apparemment ne veulent
pas voter ce texte est ce qu'il y à un
risque que ce texte ne passe pas au
sénat qu'elle a la majorité ne peut pas
être aussi franche qu'à l'assemblée
c'est ces villes et lieux dits mais vous
avez remarqué une chose c'est que sur ce
texte
l'ensemble de la gauche c'est-à-dire aux
radicaux c'est à dire communiste c'est à
dire écologie c'est à dire socialistes
se sont mobilisé fortement à l'assemblée
et ce très mobilisée au sénat et puis
vous avez vous aimez vous avez remarqué
aussi que ce projet qui qui ne touche
pas aux questions sociales et
économiques fait des adeptes aussi à
droite
il y a on l'a vu à l'assemblée de façon
des parlementaires qui considère que
c'est ces avancées je le répète un en
espagne les conservateurs n'ont pas
remis en cause mais en grande bretagne
les conservateurs ont eux mêmes proposé
le projet de loi et il est passé sur ça
veut rien dire parce que je suis très
respectueux du débat c'est pour cela
aussi qu'on ne peut pas dire il faut
voter conforme ça ça me rien dire ça si
ça vient au sénat et si le sénat existe
c'est parce qu'il a toujours la
possibilité
il a toujours la possibilité de débat de
bouger à votre avis est-ce que c'est
seulement les sénateurs qui peuvent
vouloir amender peut-être que le
gouvernement après l'ensemble des débats
qui ont eu lieu à la salle est considère
que sur telle ou telle question mais pas
sur ce droit qui est acté et qu'on va
acter monsieur sur l'a10 mais voilà il
yal c'est la finesse le travail
parlementaire il faut absolument qu'il
s'agit du code civil il faut absolument
qu'ils soient irréprochables pour
pouvoir
dans la pratique ne posez ensuite aucun
problème c'est important que la pratique
soit envisagée quand on fait la loi et
c'est d'ailleurs mon travail à la hausse
et n'a comme président de la commission
de contrôle de l'application des lois
parce que l'application c'est aussi
important que la fabrication du travail
sur ce texte visiblement quelques petits
points à améliorer
eh bien c'est ce que fait la commission
évalue la commission et je pense que
c'est pour cela d'ailleurs que il n'ya
pas dire a priori qu'il faut voter
conforme pour gagner du temps
on avait un niveau conforme à une
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée
j'imagine pas votre conforme alors mardi
a aussi été un jour de manifestations
nouveau rendez vous organisé par des
salariés d'entreprises menacées de plans
sociaux ou de fermeture ils se sont
retrouvés devant le siège de goodyear
qui n'a pour l'instant pas trouvé de
repreneur salariés de goodyear mais
aussi renault arcelor ou encore sanofi
ou psa tous en colère contre une
politique qu'il juge trop frileuse en
écoute c'est quand on voit ce qu'on voit
là les gants même de quoi être
scandalisé d'avec un gouvernement de
gauche qui prône le dialogue social à
tous vents qui en réalité fait tout le
contraire dans dans la dans les faits
quoi parce que moi je n'ai jamais vu
autant de forces de l'ordre réunis pour
un cce où dès salariés viennent dire
qu'ils veulent garder leur boulot on
n'est pas des casseurs faut pas se
tromper
la direction de goodyear celle
d'aujourd'hui qui met le feu aux poudres
s'il avait pas d' annonces de fermeture
on serait pas dans la rue c'est vrai
chez goodyear chez vrai chez peugeot
c'est vrai chez fralib c'est vrai c'est
alors c'est vrai partout
la seule loi qui vaille le coup dans ce
pays pour se protéger les travailleurs
des licenciements c'est l'interdiction
des licenciements interdire aux patrons
de fermer les usines interdire de
licencier parce qu'on est en pleine
crise économique alors dans l'automobile
ya un recul des ventes est alors est-ce
que ça à nous de payer les frais de
cette politique les frais de cette
situation il ya de la colère et du
désespoir
on a vu le week-end dernier l'ailé
gauche du parti socialiste
exiger du gouvernement un virage plus
sociale or un set au porte-parole du ps
qu'on s'adresse c'est pourquoi cette loi
sur les licenciements boursiers on en
parle encore où on n'en parle plus il ya
des 10
shaw et notamment quand même cette
semaine il y a 'l'annonce par le présent
la république lui même qu'une loi sur la
reprise des sites rentables soit la même
chose c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose mais il y a aussi dans l'ensemble
des autres d d d d d autre combat qu'on
mène sur le front de l'emploi parce que
vraiment c'est tout azimut cette
mobilisation et notamment ce qu'est la
négociation sociale et qui se poursuit
on va voir mais le groupe à l'assemblée
nationale va déposer ce projet de loi on
il faut absolument effectivement suivi
on va expliquer tout de même cette loi
forcerait les sites rentables qui
voudraient procéder à un licenciement
collectif a tenté de retrouver un
repreneur
la question se pose d'interdire un
repreneur s'est par exemple parce leur
métal c'est le cas arcelormittal avait
dit non aux fermes et même s'il ya des
repreneurs on l'interdît bien ça n'est
pas possible il faut qu'ils aient la
reprise la possibilité de reprise par
grand repreneur ou même la possibilité
en scope par exemple que les
travailleurs eux mêmes se constitue en
coopérative puisse postuler à la reprise
de l'entreprise avec un projet
mystérieux parfois il ya aussi la
difficulté à travers ses relations
enfin après ça suffit ces sujets là la
limite pour site rentable ou pas parce
que ça les économies disent que c'est
souvent très difficile bien puisque les
économistes jugent que c'est difficile
ça veut dire qu'il faut se mettre
d'accord travailler sur les normes qui
définissent rentable ou pas rentable et
c'est pour cela que le groupe est en
train de travailler va proposer ensuite
y aura un débat
bien entendu il faut une définition
assez exacte pour pas que cela produise
d'autres contentieux par la suite vous
avez raison mais enfin par exemple si on
prend les cas d'école arcelormittal
on peut dire que c'est voilà
il y avait des projets qui permettait
tous les cas la rentabilité et qu' il y
à un moment donné on a décidé
brutalement pour d'autres raisons
spéculatives et au niveau international
puisque des raisons sur le site lui-même
d'arrêter autres textes aussi l'accord
sur la sécurisation de l'emploi
on dit souvent qu'à l'assemblée ou au
sénat qu'il faudrait nouveautés tel quel
par contre on entend aussi l'ailé gauche
qui dit non non nous on est là aussi
pour eux exister tout à l'heure vous dit
que les parlementaires sur la pour
amender alors est-ce qu'il faut amender
ce texte ou pas moi je pense qu'à partir
du moment où nous avons insisté sur le
fait qu' on devait prioriser sur tout ce
qui touchait à l'emploi la négociation
sociale justement la négociation il ne
faut pas déstabiliser un accord qui a
été pris entre les organisations
patronales la cmdt est donc un accord
dit majoritaire un même si certains
contestent même ce terme
non parce que ça serait un petit peu
changé ce qui a été fait au trébuchet
mais en même temps la transcription doit
être une transcription tout à fait
fidèle de ce qui était l'engagement
notamment pour les salariés parce que
nous sommes attentifs à cela et
d'ailleurs
le gouvernement l'a fait il a plutôt
reçu un aval de la part des partenaires
sociaux bien entendu cette transcription
l'assemblée nationale comme le sénat va
devoir a encore son mot à dire
je ne pense pas qu il faut d équilibrer
les choses je pense qu'il ya d'autres
projets de loi qui doivent aborder
toutes les questions qui ne sont pas
régulés à travers cet accord mais quand
il y a en contrepartie de cette
adaptabilité des entreprises une lutte
contre ce qui est un fléau pour l'emploi
dans notre pays qui est la précarisation
et les contrats qu'aux je pense que
voilà c'est l'état d'un rapport de force
social et en même temps c'est assez
unique que avec la négociation qui était
interrompu depuis de nombreuses années
qu'on a réhabilité
il puisse y avoir quelque chose
aujourd'hui où les partenaires sociaux
se mettent d'accord
encore une fois le mardi il y avait un
autre cri de colère cette fois dans la
rue ce sont les professeurs qui ont
manifesté un peu partout en france pour
réclamer entre autres le report à 2014
de la réforme des rythmes scolaires et
notamment voit ses images ici à paris
d'une forte mobilisation
ça fait cinq fois qu'ils se mobilisent
en à peine trois semaines ce sont c'est
un électorat qui a beaucoup voté pour
françois hollande on est en train de les
perdre
moi je ne pense pas je pense que là il y
appartient aux bouches quelque chose ça
bouge les emplois du temps des modes de
vie ça bouge beaucoup de choses hein pas
seulement pour les professeurs pour les
parents aussi et donc voilà il y a des
craintes notamment sur la façon dont ça
va s'appliquer ils veulent peser là
dessus voilà c'est le jeu normal qu'il
faut accepter et en même temps sur le
fond il s'agit du primaire c'est deux
tiers des 60000 postes que nous créons
au moment où partout il ya plutôt des
suppressions ou alors des
non-remplacements si les autres
ministères mais il y à là en tous les
cas un tel effort pour refonder l'école
qui concentrait sur le primaire
rétablissement de la formation des
maîtres les rased l'accueil des élèves
handicapés sur un tissu de la part de
l'enseignant qui se retiennent que
l'érotisme jeu là c'est via les moyens
de faire bien d'enfin mettre le paquet
sur le moment où savent où ça commence à
déraper dans le système scolaire parce
que nos résultats sont là quand on est
dans les plus mauvais élèves de l' ocde
c'est pas la réputation de la france en
ce qui concerne son école donc il faut
vite rectifier cette trajectoire
parce que la droite à casser l'école
pendant dix ans systématiquement après
est-ce que la pause c'est en fin de
journée ou entre midi et deux heures
quels sont les compensations et les
facilités pour les professeurs bien
entendu tout cela fait partie de la
négociation il ya eu peut-être le
sentiment que ça devait s'appliquer
comme ça et de façon uniforme
les choses ont été rétablies on a pu
s'adresser aussi directement à tout le
monde pour qu'ils comprennent et
aujourd'hui et on a le temps 1 il y à
fin mars il y as jusqu'à juillet pour
établir des choses de façon concrète
je pense que cette vraiment cette
réforme doit être mise en oeuvre
on s'est battu quand on a enlevé cette
demi-journée soussou darcos et les mêmes
syndicats lé même syndicat d'enseignants
se sont battus et donc aujourd'hui ont
rétabli et il faut trouver la meilleure
façon comme ça que ça soit pour les
enfants que ça aille au bout allez on va
passer au mercredi 3 % un chiffre remise
en cause
c'est un engagement pris envers l'europe
les déficits publics en 2013 devrait
être ramené en 2013 donc à 3% du produit
intérieur brut didier migaud président
de la cour des comptes et le premier
mardi à mettre en doute le respect de
ses 3 % et mercredi c'est le premier
ministre lui-même qui reconnaît que
l'engagement sera très difficile à tenir
elisa bartholomé le gouvernement est
rattrapé par une situation économique
etc ces crabes et les mauvaises
nouvelles s'enchaînent croissance nulle
en 2012 alors que le gouvernement
attendait 0,3 pour cent des chiffres qui
n'augure rien de bon pour la croissance
en 2013
bercy l'estimait à 0,8 pour cent nous
constatons que le chiffre de la
croissance n'est pas bon pour l'année
2012 c'est autour de 0% et donc nous
savons aussi que la croissance 2013
devra être repensée dans le cadre des
procédures qui existent une croissance à
repenser un déficit public à revoir
après la cour des comptes et françois
hollande le premier ministre lui même
l'admet l'objectif du déficit à moins de
3% en 2013 est intenable mais le
gouvernement continue de tabler sur un
déficit nul en 2017 ne seront pas
exactement
je pense aux 3% en 2013 pour une raison
simple c'est que la croissance
aujourd'hui en france en europe et dans
le monde est plus faible que prévu mais
en tout cas l'objectif
je vous le rappelle est il sera atteint
c'est notre cap c'est l'équilibré 0 le
déficit zéro à la fin qu de cana de
françois hollande
une pirouette pour nuancer une situation
préoccupante
l'opposition ne se prive pas d'accabler
le gouvernement jean françois copé
indique dans les échos vouloir déposer
une motion de censure à l'assemblée
nationale objectif inciter françois
hollande a changé de politique
économique
david assouline n'est pas toujours été
un européen convaincu est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est abandonner roxy
très petit faut-il abandonner
aujourd'hui cette contrainte des 3%
je crois que le premier midi s'est dit
les choses clairement
c'était une trajectoire et il fallait
tout faire pour que ce soit atteint tous
les cas ce que le gouvernement a fait
est sans précédent et ans après il ya
aussi la conjoncture autour des pots un
petit peu et dont nous sommes aussi
depuis le début de l'année puis la
campagne électorale de françois hollande
c'est pas une proposition non non ce qui
est l'objectif qui sera peut-être un
dogme est vraiment l'objectif c'est
déficit 0 en 2017 c'est à dire sur le
quinquennat
ben ouais t'as victoire et on a
tellement pris nos responsabilités pour
ça que que c'est absolument bon encore
dérisoire la façon dont la droite se
comporte t-il pas dans l'intérêt des
pays du faux je vais vous dire
l'objectif tripes par la droite elle
même quand elle est était aux affaires
pour qu'ils soient et ses engagements
vis-à-vis de l'europe pour qu'il soit
maintenu et que la parole soit honoré a
fait que dès que nous avons été au
pouvoir
nous avons dû l'été c'est un collectif
budgétaire
rectificatif pour aller chercher 7
milliards que la droite n'avait pas
prévu vers il ya point que les objectifs
encore un collectif de graphistes
histoire ou pas je pense que les choses
sont différentes puisque c'est un
problème européen et mondial et que la
commission européenne a jugé par rapport
à ses engagements
si c'est parce que la france n'a pas
fait les efforts nécessaires ou six par
l est sur la bonne voie et que
l'objectif qui est le plus important
c'est à dire déficit 0 en 2017
on est sur cette voie et je pense que
les signaux envoyés par leur art go le
gouvernement dit du gouvernement va
provoquer ceux des bars je pense en
avril comme c'est à chaque fois le cas
au début au début du printemps et nous
verrons ce qu'il faut faire à ce
moment-là mais en tous les cas et c'est
là que le débat droite gauche existe
quand ils nous critiquer tu dit il qui
disent qu'ils vont faire une motion sans
sûr c'est que nous sommes nous convaincu
qu' il n'y a aucune issue y compris pour
contenir les déficits
avec le tout austérité et qu'il faut
continuer à la croissance allait la
chercher
l'emploi à maintenir la justice dans
toutes nos décisions et donc c'est dans
ce cadre là qui est la recherche de la
croissance
la bagarre pour l'emploi et la justice
sociale que nous prendrons nos décisions
or eux qu'est ce qu'ils disent je ne
sais pas mais en tous les cas partout
ils ont défendu le tout austérité ils
veulent réduire encore plus ses dépenses
peut-être qu'il ya des économies
c'est sur un ferry scié et là mais en
tous les cas pas casser les services
publics pas être contre la création
d'emplois à l'école par exemple est ce
que on veut qu'ils aient moins de santé
il ya des piliers qu'il faut maintenir
parce que on sait que ce sont des points
d'appui demain pour rebondir et sortir
de la crise parce que vous parlez de la
droite il ya un nom qui est revenu cette
semaine c'est celui de nicolas sarkozy
dans la voix d'alain juppé qui dit
sentir que nicolas sarkozy a envie
d'être candidat en 2017 nous l'annoncent
qui a laissé quand même perplexe les
députés écouter nicolas sarkozy les
jeunes
il a nous considérons qu'il a réussi son
mandat de président de la république et
je pense aussi les français à voter
aujourd'hui sans doute qui lui ferait
confiance et le moment venu nous verrons
qui est le mieux placé pour défendre nos
couleurs
mais ce ne sera pas avant 2016 je crois
pas que la sanctification du passé soit
la réponse soit qu'il faut être capable
de
de regarder notre notre bilan en face si
alain juppé le sens comme ça c'est
peut-être j'ai pas il a une autre
sensibilité que les autres mais je vous
garantis que quand on parle avec des
colas sarkozy
on n'a pas l'impression aujourd'hui il
est véritablement pris sa décision
david assouline vous sentez vous aussi
que nicolas sarkozy ait envie de revenir
moi je suis pas j'ai pas de relation
directe avec fut point si le jour vous
êtes un fin politique vous connaissez
bien donc moi je pense qu'il n'a jamais
renoncé à revenir et puis voilà donc
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il a prises la
politique de très près c'est évident
enfin bon sûr qu'ils vont douter y
compris et je jouais quand et où cet
affront 6e coupe et non pas été je pense
pour pour permettre à l'eau de se
détacher vraiment comme leader
incontesté mais ça ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il a pris sa décision et qui le sera
à sa cesser la prévoyance collective
mais le fait de ne pas s'interdire de
sécu c'est une évidence et et voilà un
sénateur de paris je voudrais vous poser
une question nathalie kosciusko morizet
sera la candidate de l'ump à paris entre
autres à l'est en tout cas candidate aux
primaires oui quel et vous en pensez à
la ce premier écueil d'ailleurs à passer
qui est ce que j'ai l'impression
m'appelle mardi ce sont là depuis
longtemps où a longtemps dans tous les
cas qui sont implantés ne voit pas ça
d'un bon oeil et donc ils livrent à
leurs actionnaires
est ce que la loi francs par an moi
franchement je vais vous dire les choses
l'essentiel pour nous n'est pas de
regarder qui aura en face c'est de venir
à qu'un projet c'est devenir vraiment
avec un nouveau projet devant les
parisiens ou le logement le
développement économique et s'appuyer
sur nos acquis peut-être enfin pour
l'instant c'est un édit une passion à
qu'elle avait déclaré il ya quelques
semaines aux habitants non jumeaux elle
est maire de longjumeau son passé son
implantation sa proximité avec les
habitants
c'était là bas et on leur a dit aux
voeux je ne vous abandonnerai pas puis
là elle vient non grasse navigo dit elle
passe navigo pas mais je répète notre
problème n'est pas de focaliser
c'est c'est le sujet de la droite
apparaît c'est que elle n'a pas réussi à
faire émerger un projet pour tous les
parisiens et pas seulement pour ceux qui
veulent rester dans leur pré carré dans
l'ouest parisien elle s'est battue s'est
battu nous verrons donc à ce moment là
mais ce que je veux dire là c'est que
pas d'illusions sur madame kosciusko
morizet elle a été la porte parole de la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy qui a été
des plus réactionnaires notamment vous
souvenez vous dans la dernière période
ça flirter avec les malheurs du front
national elle était la porte parole de
cela et je ne pense pas que c'est l'état
d'esprit des parisiens et quand elle
s'abstient sur le mariage pour tous eh
bien elle montre un manque de courage
absolue à assumer sa position elle a
fait elle a fait les amendements de
suppression des principaux articles donc
mais parce que l loi considéré qu' on
peut en politique tromper toujours tout
le monde en faisant croire qu'on est et
pour et contre
mais en politique il faut incarner et à
des moments et avoir bien commencé pour
paris le fait de céder le mariage hors
jeu je le dis assez clairement je pense
que c'était une position pas courageuse
électoraliste pour dire et à ceux qui
sont pour et ceux qui sont content je
suis peut-être avec vous et ne pas
assumer une position et je ne sais
toujours pas d'ailleurs quelle est sa
position si je regarde ce qu'elle a fait
c'est des amendements de suppression des
articles ça veut dire qu'elle est contre
le mariage pour tous
si je regarde concrètement mais elle
veut laisser entendre que elle est plus
ouverte que ça je crois que les
parisiens aux besoins et de fidélité et
de connaissance des dossiers de paris et
de souffle qu'incarne la candidate que
je soutiens anne hidalgo
parce que et elle a l'expérience et en
même temps elle a vraiment envie qu'on
ouvre une nouvelle pas notamment ce
grand paris des citoyens c'est l'horizon
de demain allez on passe au jeudi
le sénat est décidément fâché avec la
loi brottes
on vous en avait déjà beaucoup parlé de
ce texte retoqué une première fois en
octobre dernier les sénateurs
eh bien l'on voté mais sans l'article
majeur qui institue un bonus malus pour
les tarifs de l'énergie rejeter encore
une fois avec les voix des communistes
et de la droite nathalie diwar voter oui
mais sans la principale mesure mercredi
soir les sénateurs ont rejeté l'article
1er il instaurait pourtant un bonus
malus sur la facture d'énergie
une disposition loin de faire
l'unanimité et qui empêchaient les
communistes de voter ce texte aux côtés
de la majorité sénatoriale jeu le vote
parce que l'article ans a disparu et ça
pour nous c'est une grande victoire
on n'est plus dans l'hypothèse
bonus malus et nous nous pouvons le
mettre à notre crédit on s'est bien
battu sur cette idée le texte a été
adopté par 176 voix contre 139
seul l'ump a voté contre pour ce
sénateur la gauche a fait preuve
d'hypocrisie
je regrette que les parlementaires qui
finalement voté au texte l'epl courage
de reconnaître entre lucidité que
c'était une victoire qui ne pourrait
être savouré que pendant quelques heures
ou quelques jours
car c'est bien l'assemblée nationale qui
a le dernier mot elle devrait examiner à
nouveau cette proposition de loi au
printemps et procéder enfin à son
adoption définitive
bon vous allez très court parce que
finalement on le sait c'est encore une
fois les communistes qui vous posent
problème oui enfin sur ce débat on sait
que ya des incompréhensions
à gauche on est à peu près d'accord sur
ce qu'il faut faire mais la formule
proposée ne ne convainc décidément pas
les sénateurs communistes interroge est
en tous les cas un projet global sans
cet article a été voté donc il y a de la
bonne volonté mais maintenant ça suit
son cours sera sûrement réintroduit en
seconde lecture l'assemblée nationale et
pour terminer une petite séquence
hémicycle comme les députés savent nous
en concocter parfois c'était mardi lors
des questions au gouvernement
les esprits étaient très certainement
chauffé par la perspective du vote du
mariage pour tous quelques minutes plus
tard au menu de sécu âgées l'opposition
qui quitte ses bancs et un nom d'oiseau
venue du perchoir compte rendu de cette
science ahmed tazir quand on cherche
claude bartolone au le trou et dans
quelques instants
le dérapage de ce mardi tout est parti
d'une question posée par jean louis
borloo le président du parti centriste
sur le budget européen
la question est posée au premier
ministre n'était pas lui qui va répondre
comment ça
pas possible on respecte plus le groupe
eut des ihu vernement quoi on veut le
premier ministre c'est le gouvernement
qui est choisi calais le ministre qui
doit répondre vous vous asseyez ces
dernières semaines le ministre des
affaires européennes qui s'y colle pas
assez important pas assez grand pas à
ses premiers ministres cour qu'elle vous
plaît c'est la bronca les parlementaires
de l'udps et y rejoint par leurs
collègues de l'ump quittent l'hémicycle
le sens du président de l'assemblée
nationale ne fait qu'un tour
l'intrigué nobu qui parlait de la
république regardez l'image de goudet de
la république il tente de calmer le jeu
c'est le mot play calmer vos le maître
d'école face à ces élèves mais arrêtez
c'est pas un comportement voire il ait
les nerfs comme on dit en scène a mis sa
circonscription
alex ortec brut et le mot est lancé
ils jégo député udi ne lâche pas la
frères commencent à une traite d'abrutis
le patron de l'assemblée
parlant d'abrutis j'espère que il n'y a
pas derrière les propos lancés une
quelconque mise en cause de la qualité
des élus nous sommes tous des élus du
peuple pris le doigt dans le pot de
confiture claude bartolone tente une
explication en citant guy de maupassant
gens vous dire que si jean dreuil cette
expression elle me qualifier comme
disait mon passants guy de maupassant
j'étais abrutis de souffrance et de mes
connaissances je crois que c'était son
expression 1 c'est lui qui était abruti
par les événements c'est pas les députés
véhicule son contrat pro mais peu
bernard cazeneuve le pas souhaité lui
aussi veut faire bonne figure il a aussi
sa citation
le philosophe alexis de tocqueville
avait écrit dans la démocratie en
amérique que les centristes sont
violemment modéré et bien les
philosophes parfois se tromper
violemment modéré ou pas on a parlé de
lui dit ce jour là et aussi de
tocqueville maupassant à ces écrivains à
la rescousse des politiques
il va lire on est cultivée à l'assemblée
nationale et on sait sont accrochés aux
branches
je comprends qu'il y ait un peu de
l'électricité dans l'air aujourd'hui
mais on va essayer de se calmer
également du côté du sénat ses dépens
moi j'ai connu des moments mais c'est
vrai que là à l'assemblée c'est
quasiment à toutes les questions que la
loi sur le non cumul des mandats elle
pourra avoir un effet non écoutez moi
j'espère qu'elle va s'appliquer et
qu'elle va s'appliquer dès 2014 comme
c'était ce que dit manuel valls alors il
dit ce qu'il pense et là ya peut-être un
désaccord mais en tous les cas le parti
socialiste est très engagé pour que cet
engagement soit tenue dès 2014
c'est ce qu'ont voulu les militants et
on voit bien bon c'est vrai qu'elle est
problèmes d'application notamment pour
les députés qui qui devrait démissionner
si vous voulez rester maire mais en même
temps quand ils se sont présentés aux
législatives
ils le savaient donc s'il voulait rester
maire il aurait pu y penser aussi à ce
moment là et donc c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs qu'on a encore un grand débat
en perspective en tout cas entre le
parti socialiste le sénat l'assemblée
on aura bien sûr le temps d'y revenir
mais bon je veux vraiment on a une
détermination à aller au bout mais a pas
en faire un débat caricatural parce
qu'on comprend les difficultés de le
faire avant 2017
mais en tous les cas nous nous sommes
très engagés pour cette réforme
merci beaucoup david assouline merci où
l'on se retrouve mais la semaine
prochaine prochain